i'm not very interested in things that
can't change or don't change so i think
all of us can make the most of our
potential and that's the bit as a social
psychologist that fascinates me
the challenge is how do you do it how do
you do it and when i looked at these
self-help books i realized that
hey friends and welcome back to deep
dive if you're new here my name is ali
and this is the weekly podcast where
every week i sit down with entrepreneurs
creators authors and other inspiring
people and we talk about how they got to
where they are and the lessons and
strategies that we can learn from them
that will help us hopefully live our
best lives what you're about to hear is
a conversation between me and professor
richard wiseman richard is a professor
of psychology who's written a bunch of
books about the interesting quirky
aspect of positive psychology and he's
published over a hundred peer-reviewed
academic papers in the field of
psychology in interesting topics like
paranormal stuff illusions magic and
interestingly he's written a whole book
about the concept of luck and how we as
individuals can become luckier he also
happens to be a member of the inner
magic circle which is one of my items on
my bucket list that i'm working on the
audition for and he also happens to have
a youtube channel with over 2.4 million
subscribers just to add to his long list
of accolades this is a pretty eclectic
conversation that spans a wide gamut of
areas from things like luck and
paranormal and like psychology and magic
and like all a bunch of really cool
stuff i hope you enjoy the conversation
as much as i did so you have had a very
very kind of
quirky career shall we say oh um you are
the professor in public understanding of
psychology at the university of
hertfordshire correct you've written 12
books i think so the last one published
apparently over 100 academic papers in
psychology of magic illusion deception
luck self and self development yeah um
which is and i think that's what a kind
of in in in the early days when i
discovered 59 seconds and your work i
was like oh this guy's really cool he's
like he's like an academic and he's into
magic and he's into personal development
and i was into all of those things as
well so i kind of sort of looked at you
as being like oh this is this is like a
really interesting career that i maybe
want one at some point um
i guess you know one of one of the
questions that we we often ask here on
the podcast is
like how how did all this happen i guess
for you there's like a lot of kind of
background but i'm i'm curious like how
did it all happen i think about the
beginning like what what were we doing
magic magic is is really what kicked it
off so um i used to go and see my
grandfather of the weekends and one
weekend he showed me a magic trick and
in fact every weekend we went he showed
me the same trick it's a really really
great trick where you initial a coin he
made it disappear and it appeared in a
box that was sealed with elastic bands
and he said this really and i like
everyone who watched magic tricks i
always wanted to know how that was done
and he was super
wise actually because he said i'm not
going to tell you the answer what i will
tell you is where the answer is where
the solution is it's in the local
library
and that made me go and read these books
in the library and at the time i was
i'm not great readers i was struggling
with i was in sort of uh specials or
classes for reading and so on but now i
was really motivated so i read all these
books on magic got completely hooked on
it i thought it was a wonderful thing
and so became fascinated with that
thought that i would become a
professional magician started doing kids
shows and um street magic not very far
from here actually in covent garden oh
you were in the common garden yeah yeah
so cotton garden uh for a little while
not very long yeah and then
i sort of realized that wasn't
for me it's it is a very
challenging way of earning a living and
i've gone to america and i've done some
magic there and and it just it just felt
like i didn't really want to be pursuing
that as a as a career so how how old
were you around this i'd have been 17 18
or something like that okay right and
had all these wonderful experiences so a
friend and i uh actually very famous um
neuroscientist went to america i started
performing magic over there we went to
times square new york which is pretty
rough then there's all these people
doing the three-card trick
and i said to my friend i'll count all
the number of people involved in the
gangs isn't just the person throwing the
cards there's loads of people involved
with spotters and enforcers and so on we
counted them and i think we got to 12
people
and then i realized there were 13 people
because while i was counting the 12 the
13th has stolen my bag from between my
legs
and i got all my props in it and and all
of my friends slides for a job talk and
so on
and so i went from there to the magic
castle
on the west coast to perform with no
props
and i arrived and i was sitting in a a
restaurant the day before i was supposed
to start
pretty much in tears because i was
thinking my goodness this is just this
big show in front of all my peers this
amazing place called the magic castle
and i've got no props and this very
lovely woman came over sat down so
what's the problem i explained and she
said i'm not surprised you're upset
you're focusing on what you can't do you
can't go and give that show tomorrow you
haven't got time to to build the props
and so on
so let's focus on what you can do what
show can you do tomorrow and it just was
like a switch it just flipped i thought
i can do this i can do that i can do
that and i got on with it i built a show
and went out and did it it was fine
and it was that simple moment of
thinking oh my goodness i was thinking
about it one way i was i i can't do
attitude and just by flipping and going
so what what can we do right now yeah
and and so i got interested in
psychology
and and
and so i i then from there i started to
read about psychology and then did
undergraduate degree in ucl again not
very far from here
at the end of that
just by chance it was the weirdest thing
i was walking through the cloisters at
ucl bumped into the same friend actually
the person i've been to
to america with and he said i've just
seen a poster advertising for a phd
position and you have to remember this
is before email and all this sort of
stuff and the internet
and people put posters up so i said what
is it at least someone's looking uh is
up in edinburgh and they're looking for
someone to do a phd on psychology
deception
and you you love magic and you're into
psychology this would be perfect and it
was a guy called professor robert morris
who's a parapsychologist interested in
the paranormal
and he'd got some some grant money and
so i went up and and um
saw him got the position and so spent
four years up in edinburgh looking at
psychics and mediums and so on and then
from there i went back down to
university hertfordshire and that's
where i've been ever since looking at
all these kind of weird topics okay so
that's my my long-winded way of saying i
went from magic to psychology to
parapsychology and now do what i do
interesting you were performing at the
magic castle at the age of 18 yeah so
you must be very good because that's
quite like a prestigious it's it's it's
it's quite this um i was okay i mean i i
could hold my own as it were and i can
be mildly amusing when i need to be yeah
it was i went there three times actually
and it was it was great but it was the
the weird thing was it's like all these
things isn't it it was the meeting with
that woman that actually was far more
influential than performing at the the
castle it's always these weird kind of
little quirks that you think oh my
goodness it put me off in a different
direction which i think is why i then
returned to study the psychology of luck
later on because i just became
fascinated with these chance meetings we
like to think we're in charge of our
careers and i don't think we are i i
think there's so much rolling of the
dice out of it yeah it's i mean so that
was another area that i did want to talk
to you about because
i often get people approaching me and
asking for essentially career career
advice in one form or another they're
like oh you used to be a doctor and then
you switch to become this like youtuber
thing and like how does that work and
how do you like follow your passions and
things from my perspective it's you know
i i guess looking back and connecting
the it's very easy to connect the dots
and kind of weave a narrative that oh i
was interview into web design when i was
young and then got into magic and then
got into performance got into teaching
and that led to this but like at the
time it's just a sort of um kind of a
serendipitous encounter with someone or
something or i don't know coming across
one of your books or then discovering
darren brown and be like whoa this guy
like that or you know just little things
here and there that lead down a certain
path what's your take on this idea of
kind of luck as a as abroad well yeah so
the luck stuff i was at hearts had been
at hearts for 10 years i was
interviewing people for somebody else's
project actually i'd stepped in it
wasn't my project interviewing people
about moments key moments in their lives
and this guy came in and just described
himself as really lucky he said i got
this chance the currencies they always
work out for me and bump into people
and increasingly convinced that we are
presented with opportunities all the
time and it's whether we make the most
of them i think it's really easy to
think this is my career path you know
i'm going to be a medic or i'm going to
be a magician or whatever it is
and once you lock into that the problem
is you then miss opportunities or other
ways of thinking and doing
and that happened at that moment you
know i'd i was interviewing this guy and
i thought luck is really interesting
topic actually and psychologists have
pretty much ignored it
so i started to do some work on
psychology of luck and and we ran some
newspaper articles saying you know if
you think you're lucky or unlucky
contact richard wiseman and there's
about a thousand people getting contact
and it grew the media liked it as a
topic
and then that became the basis for the
the very first book and i never intended
to be an author at all so i struggled to
read even so it just wasn't something
that i intended to do it just kind of
came along so you were i i guess were
you trying to publish academic papers in
psychology journals exploring the idea
of luck absolutely i was doing that and
i published quite a lot of papers
and then
through a guy called simon singh who's
amazing sort of mathematician and public
communicator
he introduced me to his agent patrick
walsh incredible agent and patrick said
what are you working on and i actually
at the time was working mainly on the
paranormal so we put together this book
proposal about the paranormal
no publisher wanted to to really put it
out it was a chance conversation with
patrick he said what was she doing i
started doing stuff on luck
and
he said we tried to make people luckier
i said yeah we do that with
interventions and so on and that was the
the basis again of the the very first
book
okay so many questions about the
paranormal stuff as well before we go
down that so i'll just put a bookmark on
there uh in is it the luck factor the
lucky luck factor factor yeah so you've
got like four principles
um that people use to become luckier i
wonder if you can kind of elaborate on
those because i'm sure our listeners
would be very so these are the
principles the different ways in which
people like which lucky people think and
behave
so we have they're open to opportunities
and when those opportunities come along
they make the most of them and you saw
that all the time they're very flexible
so they've got an end point they knew
they wanted to i don't know be
successful or you know financially
well-off or whatever it was but the way
they were going to get there they didn't
really know they were looking at the way
the wind was blowing and then setting
sail to make the most of that very
flexible
folks
second they tend to trust their
intuition
and when they get that gut feeling they
really do treat it as an alarm bell and
take it quite seriously
third they're optimists and so that
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy they
they kind of continue in the face of
failure and and so on and fourth and i
think it's probably the most important
principle uh they're extremely resilient
so when bad things happen they could
bounce back
and so you know i remember i interviewed
to hundreds of lucky and unlucky people
one of them was this guy that was in the
lucky group and he came in for two
interviews between the two interviews
he'd fallen down the stairs and broken
his leg it's the second interview he
comes in with his leg and a cast yeah
and i say i bet you don't consider
yourself quite so lucky now and he says
this wonderful answer which still sticks
with me he said you're kidding he said
you never know the impact of something
like this he said sure it's annoying at
the moment but he said last time i went
into hospital i fell in love with a
nurse there we were happily married 25
years later it was the best thing that
ever happened to me he said don't label
it bad luck you never know what's going
to come from this
so it's incredibly resilient sort of
attitude and so those are the four
things the opportunism uh the intuition
the optimism and the resilience and and
is that something that people can learn
or is it does it tend to be a sort of
quote innate trait and well that's a
very good question so
obviously all of us
are a mixture of
genes and and and nature and nurture
basically
and i'm not very interested in the
nature
end of things i'm not very interested in
things that can't change or don't change
so i think all of us can make the most
of our potential and that's the bit as a
social psychologist that fascinates me
the challenge is how do you do it how do
you do it and when i looked at these
self-help books i realized that this
stuff wasn't evidence-based people were
just making things up some of it might
be helpful some of it might not be
and so we started to come up with
interventions and test them and that was
the basis of luck factor
which which is these things which
actually we know make a difference
because we've done the the studies to
support it so going a little bit meta on
this like what does it look like to
test an intervention on something like
luck
if you're running the experiments yes so
i like experiments that pose exactly
those problems which is how do you do
that
um in our studies we would take groups
of people that didn't consider
themselves lucky or unlucky we'd ask
them to do something and then you
monitor that group
your problem is you haven't got a
control group
so then you know it's compared to what
basically so you can then have another
group of people that aren't doing doing
anything
problem which is good better at least
the problem there is we you don't know
that maybe it's the doing of anything
that
that kind of helps so we often have a
third group which is that we say here's
a lucky mascot or a lucky charm carry
that like to see but almost exactly
exactly and that's the sort of way you
start to take those interventions and so
what what kind of interventions are
yeah we did super simple things uh in
part because the complicated things
didn't work
so for example uh we'd ask people to
keep a luck diary and this was at the
time when positive psychology which they
now sort of falls under was was around
but it wasn't huge we were doing some
work into this so the luck diary the end
of each day you write down a sense of
gratitude you have for your friends or
health or career or whatever gratitude
intervention
or the best thing that's happened in the
last 24 hours
or
something negative that used to happen
that no longer happens okay
and what that means you start to build
up a written record and you do have to
write it if you just think it doesn't
work you start to build up a written
record of how lucky you are how
fortunate you are how good your life is
and that starts to then change people's
self-perception
and that's when you start to see these
changes in behavior changes in
perception and ultimately changes in
physical health and well-being and
financial success and so on and you can
and and you can measure all that well
yeah i mean that's what psychologists do
some of it's tiki boxy stuff yeah how
how good you feel yeah and some of it is
you know a number of trips to your gp or
longevity of relationships or income
there's much more hard measures okay
what sort of kind of numbers of people
are we talking in these kind of studies
well i mean those studies are quite old
now so at the time we're probably
running groups of 50 something like that
okay yeah so yeah because i i remember i
did psychology for my third year at
cambridge when we do the intercalated
bsc thing and there were all sorts of
posters on the thing would you like to
be paid 20 pounds to take part in a
thing with a computer game and a thing
and no one quite knows like i know this
is a psychology experiment so i know
like you know things are not quite as
they seem yeah but i had a bunch of
friends who were like 20 quid for doing
a computer game for an hour why not like
this is
great money for a student it's yeah
they're fun i mean i i like experiments
that that are meaningful i mean a lot of
psychology experiments are a little bit
on the dull end i mean psychologists are
astonishing they can take something as
wonderful as a human being and reduce it
to something really dull really quite
quickly so some of my favorite luck
studies was we would invite people to be
interviewed
but they that meant they had to go to a
certain room which meant they had to
walk along a certain corridor and we'd
put money on the corridor of the
corridor so the question is did they
spot it and the lucky people tended to
spot it and the unlucky ones didn't uh
as in lucky as in people who
self-identify as lucky always
self-identified always self-perception
okay yes um and so by the time they got
to the room for the interview the study
was finished
there is no interview it was just
whether you spotted the five or ten
pound note yeah and so i love these
things we did so many of these these
great little studies oh
there was one ah i gave it some tv show
i think darren brown maybe had something
to do with it which was university bar
where you could sort of like red and
blue coins and like the red coins would
give people actual alcohol and the blue
coins would give people placebo alcohol
okay and there was no difference in
behavior between the two groups yes
yeah i don't know that darren did that
about but yeah certainly i've done
similar stuff and then basically you
realize alcohol to a large extent is a
placebo which is a phenomenal and
darren's great dance fantastic he filmed
his first show ever uh i was part of
that first uh show and we met way back
then 20 years ago that's like darren
brown live i think it might be even mind
games all the way back okay um so it's
great yeah yeah i saw him live uh about
two weeks ago and it's an astonishing
performance oh yeah he's amazing i've
seen all of his live shows it's like
yeah awesome i actually discovered his
old old-school books pure effect and
absolute magic
great thank you
i was just like that bloody hell this
stuff is really good just a quick
interlude before we continue with the
podcast now if you are interested in for
example building good habits and
breaking bad ones and you haven't yet
read atomic habits by james clare
firstly you've probably been living
under a rock because everyone seems to
have read or at least bought atomic
habits by james claire but the other
thing is that instead of reading the
book you can get a summary of the key
ideas from the book by using short form
who are very kindly sponsoring this
episode if you haven't heard by now
short form is the world's best service
that summarizes popular non-fiction
books and on their summaries it's just
way more than book summaries they've got
one pages that summarize the key ideas
of the book in a single page but they
also have detailed chapter by chapter
summaries which mean that if you don't
want to you don't necessarily have to
read the book although in the case of
atomic habits i do still recommend
reading the book they also have
interactive exercises in between some of
the chapters so you can really engage
with the material yourself and also they
have this thing called the short form
note which is essentially where if an
author has said something that another
author has disagreed with or that is a
bit controversial then they will flag up
that hey hang on this is a thing that
there's you know there's the evidence
for this is a little bit shaky therefore
maybe don't take its word for it as
gospel truth maybe check out this book
instead that argues for the opposite so
it's just great for getting a balanced
representation of the stuff that authors
claim in these sorts of books there's
two main ways that i use short form the
first one is if i get a new book
recommendation and i'm not immediately
sold on it then what i'll tend to do is
look up the book summary of that on
short form and based on whether i like
the book summary then i will decide to
buy or not buy or read or not read the
book and secondly it's also just a great
way of revisiting ideas from books i've
already read so for example i've read
atomic habits one time but i've looked
at the short form summary for it at
least three or four times in preparation
for videos or for my life or my book
research or various other things anyway
if any of that sums up your street and
you'd also like to get access to the
world's best book summaries which are
more than just book summaries then head
over to short form dot com forward slash
deep dive and with that url you will be
getting a 20 discount of the annual
premium subscription and you'll also be
supporting this very podcast so thank
you very much short form for sponsoring
this episode and let's get back to the
show lucky journals so these things work
yeah they they work they change people's
self-perception and one of the things
that that does is then change how their
friends and colleagues um behave towards
them okay
so we forget that we give off a certain
you know self identity a vibe yeah and
that other people reinforce that okay
and so we come to convince ourselves
that's who we are yeah and then once you
start to change that and other people
see you as more successful or lucky
they'll give you more opportunities or
they'll talk to you more or whatever
it's in the same way their emotions
contagious you know that we all like
enjoy being around happy people because
it makes us feel happy and so the lucky
people tended to be happier they had a
bigger social network which meant they
got more opportunities but also when
things went wrong there were people
there to help them yeah the unlucky
people tended to be social isolates what
direction do you think the causality
goes here both ways okay both ways so
people who've had bad stuff happen to
them tend to consider themselves to be
unlucky yeah but also people who i guess
i i guess this creates a vicious cycle
of once you start considering yourself
to be unlucky you stop taking
opportunities you stop like
generating positive vibes into the world
yeah absolutely and also you know bad
things is to some extent subjective yeah
you know and and so as i say a bit like
the breaking the leg story you know that
that would to me look like a bad thing
this guy didn't perceive it like that at
all yeah so like one of the things i i
like and don't like about kind of
self-help as a thing is that you can
always reduce it down to a cliche
you know like or always look on the
bright side of life yeah i mean that's a
cliche for a reason it's like generally
good advice but
as if someone hears the advice in that
simplified format it's very easy to
dismiss as ah you know this is a bs
well so that piece so always look on the
bright side of life the question what
does that actually mean you know how do
you do that how do you do it so with
some of our work we looked at
counterfactual thinking yeah so when
something bad that you perceive as bad
has happened to you generating it could
have been worse
counterfactuals
um actually it's a fairly effective way
of being a bit more resilient or looking
for the the silver lining you know what
good things have come out of this even
if they're quite minimal and that's what
i find more interesting what are the
tactics
because often those cliches are very
broad brush yeah very sort of abstract
yeah yeah and you go yeah fine so sorry
what i do tomorrow or right now what are
the tactics
i'm sure it's in the action is always in
the tactics rather than strategy that's
interesting so the book i'm writing at
the moment is
or rather struggling to write
why are you struggling nice oh okay
interesting so we'll get into that
tangent and then i'll come back to the
thing tactics yeah i actually had a call
with my with one of our external editors
yesterday and it turned into more of a
therapy session i feel like anytime i
speak to my agent or the editor it
becomes therapy session basically
i i think it's tied up in in in my mind
the the bar is too high
so if i'm writing an email newsletter
i've been doing this every week for four
years it's chill i'll write down
whatever the hell if i feel like oh i
discovered this cool new tip in
richard's book green plant blah blah
blah bang it sends out it goes out to
people
people reply being like this is a really
good tip thank you if i'm making a
youtube video in the early days of my
channel i'd hit record on the camera
have a rough like oh i want to say these
four things about like the four
different types of block let me just
talk about it but then when it comes to
the book
it's like it feels like a big deal it's
like it's like when i sit down to write
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm i'm like mark twain
and doing writing
like whatever and it's all it's all it's
all just like a really kind of uh
pressurized way to think of writing
and what rachel our editor was saying
was that like you just just gotta lower
the stakes it's all good it's your
shitty first draft like no one cares
does that resonate still yeah in quite a
few ways are you comfortable saying what
your book is about is it absolutely no
no it's all good uh it's sort of a
practical guide to sustainable
productivity oh okay all right i love
the fact that you're struggling to write
a book on productivity
yeah there's a lot of meta examples in
there
so all i can tell you is what i've done
for for 12 books which is that and a pro
i won't do any more because
i find it a quite difficult thing to do
i i've got my idea i've got my outline i
checked my chapter outline i've got
content that's going to go in there and
i give myself
two months
to write 80 000 words oh okay
and that like that you can chunk that
down and and it's a lot of words a day
yeah and my goal is to get that those
words out it does not matter about the
quality that is my first goal okay i
fail only if i don't produce 80 000
words in two months okay
everything takes goes on to the back
burner yeah everything until you've done
whatever it is one and a half thousand
words that day so i get up
i have breakfast and until i've done one
and a half thousand words nothing
nothing else gets done oh this is nice
and and then i start the day with other
emails whatever else yeah i think and
after you've written the first draft
that first 80 000 boy is it easy
boy is it easy because now you're
editing you've got something to work
with you know the bits that didn't work
and you've worked through them really
really quickly yeah and you go back you
know that bit didn't work or now i can
shift this bit to here but if you
haven't got that if you haven't got that
that paint on the canvas it's a blank
canvas and that's a bit scary yeah so
all i would all i've ever done is i get
up i write i can only write between
about nine o'clock and around about half
past 11 in the morning okay and that's
why one and a half thousand words and
nothing gets in the way of doing that
okay that's that's sick i'm gonna i'm
gonna try that
so i think so i um so i've i've had the
deal for about a year now and in sort of
this time last year i was like you know
what i can tie pretty fast two thousand
words a day how hot can that be my book
is eighty thousand words two months bang
it out and i got to like day three i had
six to six thousand words in and i was
like hmm i don't have an outline
ah it's really hard to do without
outline
so you haven't got you haven't got a
chapter by chapter uh so i do now and
that's that's the thing that's taken the
last 12 months right and whenever my mom
asks me how's the book going i'm like
making slow progress but it it doesn't
feel tangible because there's you know
as i'm sure you've figured out what it
seems to be like there's a lot of i know
what i want to say but it's like the
structure and the packaging and the
central metaphor i'm using and all of
these other bits is
the bit that takes a lot of work to get
the flywheel going but doesn't translate
into words on the page and it needs to i
mean it needs to i i think so i have got
that structure and i've got pretty much
a structure for every thousand words i
know the point i want to make in a
thousand words and sometimes i'll sit
down and go you know i haven't got the
evidence i don't know the studies in
which case i just write and i just like
pretend i do yeah and i've got a mental
marker i don't know those ones i need to
go back to that but you need those those
80 000 in my opinion before you then go
back and start to to work on it yeah but
it's like it's you know you work so hard
on the first thousand and it's the
perfect first thousand and then you
realize it all needs to be changed
because you've changed your conclusions
later on so that was a waste of time i'm
very economical in in the way i do these
things so you've written 12 books over
the last like since 2004 or is it uh
about 2 000 i think it's like better
yeah always the same way so once i got
the 80 000 then i switched to day on day
off okay so i go back and edit day and
then i take a day off and normally do
other things then back on it again i go
day on day off for about two months and
after that the book's pretty much done
so you've written 12 now why why don't
you want to write more because it's
quite as you might find out it's quite a
lonely old process you're just there in
front of your computer occasionally
sending emails or talking to people
but i've done it quite a lot yeah i've
done questions this is the novelty after
12 months yeah yeah and then you have to
go out and publicize them and yeah and
so on so if i if i get a great idea i'll
probably go with it
but and actually i'm you know last book
i did was with david copperfield about
history of magic and that that was great
yeah yeah so something very passionate
about and you're working with you know
legendary magician a very different type
of book i'd never done a coffee table
book before so that was fun right now
i've just finished one on on my
psychology matters and that's for
psychologists and psychology students
it's not really a book for the general
public yeah and so i'm doing fun things
but the idea of 80 000 words doesn't
thrill me yeah how do you think about
your career
i don't i don't i've always just thought
am i having a good time okay is it
interesting do you want to get out of
bed in the morning and if the answer is
yes yes yes you're doing okay okay i
don't i've never had an end point
i really haven't i've just like yes it's
fun this is all right so what one of the
you know as as you know one of the
classic things in the self-help
literature is this idea of setting a
destination setting a goal manifesting
knowing what you want out of life and
then doing the things to get there yeah
how does that vibe with your experience
and your research oh it doesn't i mean
for me the goal is is it interesting
you know am i am i engaged with this
and if i am then
life is good
and there's been times when i've been
paid you know some money to do something
i'm not particularly in a project i'm
not particularly interested in and boy
that's that's hard that's work
everything else is is just playing
really so i don't have this notion of
um oh i need to be sort of financially
successful or or whatever or fame i
never wanted to be a writer yeah i
wouldn't have been on my horizon at all
you know i enjoy giving
talks and i enjoy the live stuff uh one
day maybe i'll wake up and i won't enjoy
it which i guess i'll stop doing it but
no just you know i just think
have an interesting life
you know as that's and and do good
things you know if it don't harm people
as long as you're doing stuff which you
think makes the world a better place
yeah then that will probably you know
fuel you i like that this idea of i will
i'll continue to do it for as long as
it's interesting yeah i think i think
it's the same with me the other thing is
is that the moment i cease to find it
interesting yep
it's like the paranormal or the magic
trick if i showed you a magic trick and
you didn't know how it's done
guys it's like a stone in your shoe as a
magician once said
you really want to know
and and you'll spend time trying to
figure it out and annoy if you can't and
ask questions yeah so the moment you
find out the solution boom it's gone no
interest to anyone at all it's why
magicians hold their secrets
because without that magic tricks aren't
particularly interesting same as the
paranormal ghosts you know if i say i
think this place is haunted that's kind
of interesting mysterious the moment we
find out is dodgy air conditioning or
whatever it is yeah boom it's gone yeah
so i i just think find mystery find
curiosity find interest if you're the
sort of person
that's what worked for me yeah if
someone in the early 20s was saying to
you that you know richard you've had a
very successful illustrious career
looking at your accolades you're one of
the one 100 people in britain that makes
britain a good place to live a legend
allegedly yeah the other 99 are but boy
they're terrible
what would you say is this balance
between do what you find interesting do
what you like kind of vibes versus but i
need to make money to make ends meet
well that's the thing i think know your
passion and so the little test i always
have is you're on a desert island are
you allowed four or five books but
they're only about one topic what's the
topic
and people go always think well that's
your passion probably
now
find a way of making enough money
to to get by with that topic and you
probably got the recipe for happiness
enough money enough money to get by okay
and because i mean i know quite a few
very wealthy people and often they're
not the happiest people in the world
once you get to the top of something
you've got to keep yourself there's a
lot of pressure on and so on
so yeah you know you want to be
comfortable but i i i think it's a it's
a false god to kind of go i want to be a
multi-millionaire or or whatever yeah
for me it's far more interesting to have
a good life in that in that sense how
how do you define a good life an
interesting life one where you get up in
the bed in the morning and and you think
yeah i'm actually interested in what i'm
doing
today oh you've got people around you
that share your viewpoint and you can
work with them and that you're doing
some good in the world
you know when i wrote luck factor and i
still get emails from people that say it
changed everything for me i still get
emails from clinicians who say when
people are on the slippery slope to
depression before they become depressed
they'll think themselves unlucky yeah
and that book catches them early and
it's much easier to change their way of
thinking
that's good
that's good that's not that's pretty
just making a little tiny little
contribution yeah yeah i think those
things is what unwraps it for me i was
filming a video i think like a couple
days ago i was doing like a little q a
and someone in the audience asked when
do you plan to retire and i was like hmm
and i was kind of thinking like what
does retire even mean there was some
definition i came across on twitter
which is that retirement is when you are
not
doing something today for the promise of
a reward tomorrow uh generally monetary
revenue yeah management yes
and so how do you get to that point
number one you can make loads of money
cool now you're retired because you
don't then have to quit work number two
you can have a very very very acetic
lifestyle and just not spend any money
because now a baseline level of money
will make you retired well number three
you can wake up every morning and be
genuinely excited about the things that
you're doing so that you're doing them
for their own sake rather than for the
monetary reward that they may not
generate and i think for me what i'm
trying to do is like these seem like
three decent definitions i want to do a
combination of all three so let's kind
of do the things that are that i find
energizing and to make those things help
people in some way and then figure out a
way to monetize that and
some we have some kind of recipe
i mean you're a young man what a curious
question though to ask you
when you intend to retire what what
motivated that question do you think i
think i am i'm very open about how much
money this business makes on the
internet oh i see it and so people will
be like oh okay five million revenue
this year kind of kind of stuff be like
and reverse engineer and then don't know
the difference between business finances
and personal finances assume i'm like 20
times wealthier than i actually am
personally and therefore think oh if you
uh this thing of once i have x amount of
money in the bank then i will stop
working being a thing you're you're
shaking your head i think it's crazy
unless you hate what you do yeah
or it's so incredibly stressful it's
it's basically killing you and friends
of mine who used to work in the city
were like that you know they earned a
vast amount of money but boy i wouldn't
change places for them they had no life
and and actually mostly were quite ill
early on because of the stress and and
so on so if you enjoy what you're doing
if you enjoy making the podcast and so
on that's great you know
yes you want to be making some money
from it but i suspect you know if you've
got enough money in the bank to retire
there'd be no point in retiring because
you're enjoying it yeah exactly what
you're just doing
yeah you'd just be doing it for free
after that you know so yeah
yeah that's a slightly strange question
there was and and there are a bunch of
looking into this at one point you know
a bunch of studies that show that
post-retirement people's risk of heart
disease just like five times higher or
whatever the the figures are because
there's a loss of kind of having
something to do
is like profoundly strange yes
i was i was watching a tv show i think a
couple of nights ago and there was a guy
who was exactly that as an engineer and
he'd retired and he suddenly found it
got nothing to do at all so he bought a
very old um rundown classic car
and decided to uh sort of do it up and
he said that it's incredibly challenging
because you have to know exactly what
you're doing with engines and upholstery
and stuff he said he kept him alive he
said now he's got something to get up
for in the morning yeah i was doing i
just think you you need that you
absolutely need it yeah yeah so like
over the last couple of years as you
know just for a bit of background i did
six years of med school i did my
psychology fake degree um got an m.a out
of that because cambridge fake degrees
and all that jazz and then practice as a
doctor for two years and then i took a
break in 2020 intending to travel the
world but then pandemic happened and it
was around that time that this youtube
channel really started to take off and i
was like oh okay how do i figure out
what i want to do with my life and one
strategy i found helpful was the idea of
what what would you like written on your
gravestone yeah if you imagine hopefully
many years in the future and for me i i
thought about this a bit and realized
that the three things i care about are
some combination of good father good
good husband and inspirational teacher
and i was like okay it's interesting and
i kind of connected the dots backwards i
was like all of them like a huge amount
of the meaningful moments of my life
have been when i've been teaching other
people something whether it was tutoring
maths when i was like a teenager or
getting people into med school when i
wasn't when i was med school or like
teaching medical students or any it was
all related to teaching and i thought
hmm that's interesting so it's like the
thing i care about is just actually
being able to kind of learn cool stuff
and then teach it to people and that's
actually a fairly cheap thing to be able
to do
um because internet and like writing and
things and so now what i spend my time
doing most days is just reading writing
and teaching in one form or another or
learning from people through the podcast
or making videos and it's genuinely like
amazing and energizing and fun
but and the reason i say this is one
thing i worry about is what will i be
doing when i'm 50 will i still be one of
those
hey guys welcome back to the channel
like
and i feel like
yeah any any any advice for that
particular conundrum 155 now so um
so i stopped doing the youtube stuff we
did quakeology very early adopters of it
um made loads of stuff in the bets
videos and and so on and we've had uh
500 million views on it which blows
their ways is i find that incredible
i stopped doing it
i think i thought i got nothing else to
say
with it and it was exactly that you
didn't want to be the sort of you know
55 year old guys
still cranking these things out yeah so
occasionally post on the channel but
they're they're just very small little
videos that i find interesting so i
think you just you just mature you just
move on you become something else you
know it's people change that's what's
interesting about people imagine
watching a drama when no one changed and
nothing happened yeah it'd be the
dullest thing in the world
what will become what's interesting
about all of our lives is that you will
not mature but you'll become a different
person as you age and and then
the skill set you've got now you'll use
in a different way i think i certainly
would worry about it yeah in fact we
will get knocked over by a bus tomorrow
so they're not going to do it no too
much into the future so it's interesting
what you say about teaching i have a
similar approach what i find interesting
is expanding people's minds giving it
giving people an expansive mindset i
think we all tend to
to sort of lock ourselves away in a room
in a sense mentally and just just
letting people know there's other things
they can do other ways of seeing the
world there's interesting stuff out
there i i find that quite energizing and
because sometimes
you know we forget you know there's just
there's not just one way of looking at
the world there's many many different
ways so i find that that kind of
interesting thing to be doing the
growthstone thing is interesting is a
variant on the eulogy and psychology
intervention which you imagine which is
in 59 that you imagine uh your friend is
going to stand up at your funeral and
they're going to read our eulogy and you
actually write the eulogy for them you
actually the end the intervention is you
go right it's going to be 10 years time
this is what they're going to say about
me then you look at it and go well given
what you're doing is that going to be
true and there's quite an interesting
way of of pushing yourself into the
future and thinking will they actually
be saying the things that i want them to
be saying what result do you find that
intervention has it it's slightly a
goal-setting one but also it's more than
that i think it's exactly as you say do
i want my friend to say uh oh
he was a wonderful husband
okay what's the evidence what evidence
are they going to present for that did
this and this and this well is that true
is is that the direction you're heading
in or are you so career focused you're
forgetting about your relationships yeah
so i think it gives people quite a
rounded view of themselves because you
just tend to look at both personal and
professional yeah that stuff nice yeah i
think so i didn't i didn't realize that
was like a legit into intervention i
mean i need to follow up on the on the
evidence for that definitely because i
think this is this is some of the stuff
i want to put in in my book where the
final chapter is a chapter about purpose
and
initially when i started writing the
thing chapter one was going to be about
purpose because it was like oh it's a
book about productivity
why bother driving in a direction if you
don't know what direction you're driving
in and so on and so on and i kind of
went into the rabbit hole it's it's
really hard to answer the question of
purpose as like a
26 year old at the time trying to be
like hey here's how you figure out what
to do in life yes and so now we're like
we'll put the purpose the purpose thing
at the end obviously no one's actually
genuinely figured it out but things like
eulogy gravestone this this sort of
stuff
uh does help in in a way just
rather than being as a destination to be
fixated on i think more like being a
barometer of am i currently going in the
direction that i that this thing says
that i want to be going in yeah i think
so
i mean with the i think he's one of the
you know the seven highly effective
habits the thing i think one of them
i've never read the book actually no
i think one of them definitely start
with the end in mind yeah
which is great which is great i think
the other one is know what you want to
say before you say it
and that's with in terms of writing or
speaking
that's a really helpful
tip to think hold on a second what do i
want to say i don't know what to say
i've got no chance of saying it
i might get lucky but i doubt it yeah so
i think in terms of the book writing
it's going right in this thousand words
what point do i want to make yeah if i
don't know there's no point in trying to
write those thousand words yes like
so maybe it's worth just sort of taking
a breath and going right what is the
point that i'm trying to make yeah so
this is
kind of my exact process while writing
i've i found that when i write in a
blank
note on apple notes that's when the
words words flow so because when it's in
a google doc then it feels too high
pressure yeah and i constantly come back
to whenever i'm stuck i'm just like go
back to what am i actually trying to say
and then i write down what's on my mind
and i'm like oh that's actually not bad
but there's because there's something
about like the writing that sort of it's
as you get into the weeds of it it's uh
you kind of miss the forest from the
trees and
forget oh oh actually i'm trying to say
maybe get the friend to interview you if
a friend interviewed you about these
topics yeah and then you just took that
transcript what you said your answers
yeah it might be a good starting place
that's a good idea because you're
obviously very very very happy to talk
about these things and so if the block
is sitting there in front of a computer
screen yeah then just getting someone to
interview you and then starting with
that as your transcript that might be
interesting that's a good because
because i do find when i hit record on a
camera or on a podcast i'll just say
stuff there's this one just don't worry
about it exactly where the writing is
yes
instead it's interesting you went with
apple notes or whatever i'm very old
school i love post-its i really like the
writing and and so all my stuff is
always ideas
an interesting idea post it on the wall
and then i rearrange them there's
something about the physicality of it
that's nice that i really like so that
was one of the things my editor
suggested yesterday because i i read
everything on kindle or audible or
bullet like three times speed kindle it
like highlighting all that and she was
like
try handwriting in a journal morning
pages every morning for three pages and
try actually reading physical books
slowly because there's something about
the physicality of that that helps
creativity flourish in a way that like a
computer screen
doesn't necessarily yeah and i also
think for me i mean i don't know what
works for me but sometimes i think right
imagine i have to give a talk about this
tomorrow yep so i've only got five hours
to get this thing what would i say in
that talk and i'll do the powerpoint
slides very quickly
right that's why points are like well
that's your chapter yeah but it's when
you see the whites of people i think
with writing what you can sometimes do
is it feels very distant and you sort of
sit there and write anything but when
you give a talk you see the whites of
their eyes and you go hmm this better be
interesting because otherwise people are
going to be drifting off um i think it
it
it focuses the minds yeah you say how do
you feel about affirmations i'm not a
big fan okay there's some research
showing that if you've got low
self-esteem and you do affirmations it
makes it worse because you think well i
don't even trust myself so if i say
these are terrible things other good
things about myself i'm probably lying i
i i don't go for the idea standing in
front of the mirror and saying i'm a
good person or whatever find the
evidence you know just just if you think
it you know if you want to be a kind
person do go to kind things
and and you you become that that person
not by standing in front of a mirror and
saying i am a good person yeah so
yeah i'm not huge yeah i i guess it's
sort of i guess the the other side of
the coin to
sort of the luck journal thing where
with an affirmation it's like you
haven't done the thing but you're
telling yourself you've done the thing
or you're going to do the thing whereas
like journalists like
in in what ways will i kind today it's
really concrete it's evidence-based the
carnegie i mean i love dale carnegie you
wrote that when friends influence people
had to stop worrying and start living
two of the greatest self-help books ever
slightly dated now but but still amazing
so he's got this great journaling method
which was kind of the opposite which was
journal was called daft or silly things
i've done today
and he'd write down one of the things he
really regretted
and so i wish i hadn't sort of snapped
at that person or i wish i hadn't made
this decision and then what you're going
to do in the future to prevent that
happening so he did a sort of learning
thing where he instead of running away
from a mistake he really would embrace
it as a learning opportunity
and i thought that was nice as as well
that's nice yeah it's a fun thing yeah
that i i guess that speaks to
everyone knows the cliche failure is a
learning opportunity but very few people
do the tactics exactly again it's the
tactic is yeah yeah fine sorry how do i
do that yeah well here's the answer it's
a private thing you can just write
anything you want no one's going to look
at it but then just write what you're
going to do to stop that happening in
the future it's a lovely idea yeah and
it's buried because he's you know his
books are now quite old and people
aren't looking at them but it's a lovely
lovely thought his books are amazing the
reason why they're amazing in part is
because he didn't write how to influence
and influence people immediately he went
on a speaking tour for about a decade
and and learnt how to tell those stories
and the book of the transcripts of those
talks and that's why they're such an
easy read and so engaging because when
you talk it's different to writing yeah
so different yeah it's almost like a
stand-up comic kind of perfecting their
set before doing the netflix show that's
right one of the things i think it's in
rip it up you talk about the as if
principle oh yes can you elaborate on
the as if principle please so the as if
principle is a very old idea in
psychology it goes back to william james
it's this notion that we think that our
thoughts and emotions create our
behavior which they almost certainly do
so if you feel happy you smile
but there's a kind of back channel which
is that if you
force yourself to carry out the
associated behavior influences your
thoughts and emotions i.e you force your
face into a smile and you feel happier
and that's that is a william jones
notion uh i think he refers to it as the
as if principle i'm not quite certain
now
um in other words you behave as if
and then that creates the the thoughts
and emotions i think when i was getting
into
i think i came across this concept
when i like around the time where i
discovered 59 seconds i can't remember
if you quite mention it in in that or
not it might be in there yeah it's sort
of thing which i would have given a
passing yeah like a bit of a positive
comment like we we
you know arguably we don't smell because
we're happy we're happy because we smile
or what's that effect and then when i
studied psychology you know this sort of
theories of emotion and there's some
stuff about like uh this is difficult to
replicate and like doesn't people know
if it's entirely legit but since like
2015 i haven't really thought about this
very much um until until we were doing
research on the podcast i was like oh
this relates to that thing that i
thought was a bit controversial in
psychology where some people say it's a
thing some people say it's not a thing
what's the
where does the jury stand at the moment
i don't know the the replica i think
some of the the work on i want the
facial feedback hypothesis this notion
that you force your face into an
expression and feel that emotion i think
some of that has proven difficult to
replicate
the book rip it up takes a much broader
approach and and so it's looking at
persuasion and motivation and all sorts
of things my understanding is that at
its core there's still a phenomena there
to something explained and to be used
but the replication issue was hit you
know all over
bizarrely of course motivated by
parapsychology
so
yeah the um and i have a tiny tiny role
to play in in all of this others so
a colleague of mine daryl bem as
parapsychologist so believes in
paranormally stuff
daryl did some studies which showed that
apparently people could see into the
future
i tried to replicate those studies and
couldn't replicate them
and couldn't get the null replications
published
okay yeah because journals don't like
publishing or didn't then null
replications eventually got it published
then other people started to look at
daryl's work
and go hold on a second there's a few
statistical and mythological issues here
yeah which was true and other people
then went hold on a minute though
they're all over psychology as well so
he's got a problem so psychology
and the way you get rid of those
problems is to pre-register your study
to say in advance what you're going to
do what analysis you're going to use
and when you do that
in mainstream psychology you suddenly
find out a lot of your effects drop away
but they were due to what's called
questionable research practices so this
whole current
kind of focus on the need for
application and pre-registration
actually dates back to parapsychology so
it's quite a nice little
bit on that i i was very intrigued by
the whole sort of magic deception
suddenly going into like paranormal
stuff
is there anything there in the
paranormal stuff like well yeah i mean
by anything yeah again it's that thing i
just thought you know what that sounds
like an interesting thing to do for you
really cool yeah yeah so i'll go and do
that there's something there people we
know that people have weird experiences
they see what they think a ghost they go
to a psychic who seems to be able to
predict their future or knows all about
them or whatever the experience is
totally genuine
of course there are some people that
think they are genuinely paranormal and
i'm not one of them i'm pretty skeptical
about such stuff what interests me
is not only what does explain those
experiences but more importantly what do
you learn along the way
so if you go back to
1920s for example and hans berger who's
a german scientist who has a telepathic
experience
then goes my goodness i need to build a
machine to measure brain waves leaving
the the skull
incredibly hard thing to do because
brain's pretty isolated from the outside
world but he eventually comes up with a
machine that can measure brain waves in
order to see them leaving the skull as
evidence telepathy
of course he gets no evidence telepathy
but invents the eeg machine yeah
and and so that's what i'm interested in
is not only what explains his
experiences what do you learn along the
way and and what are the spin-offs be
like you know going to the moon you know
going to the moon is one thing but
there's a lot of technological spin-offs
along the way yeah
like i think one of your recent books
about like kind of different lessons for
success and mindset and things from that
we can learn from the moon yes i love
that yeah that was that was a fun book
to do because i got to speak to the
mission controllers who put you know a
man on the moon which was phenomenal
and they were a great group again it
came about through a chance conversation
i was talking to a comedian friend of
mine helen keane who's into space stuff
about polymissions
and she was talking about the
technological spin-offs and i said what
about the psychological ones who's
looked at the mindset and the per person
on the moon yeah and she said i don't
think anyone has but you need to speak
to the mission controllers i said how
would i get in touch with them she said
you'd speak to my friend craig who at
the time was a welder from wales okay
and he was just a complete space knight
he loves space and apollo yeah and he's
befriended the ball
and so craig introduced me to this
incredible group of people
and they were really young at the time
so mission control when they started
that that work in the early 60s average
age in mission control 21 okay even when
uh armstrong
walks on the moon average age 28 yep
phenomenal
first in their families to go to college
from really modest backgrounds and so i
got to interview them about the sort of
psychology of success in that room yeah
so what were the kind of broad
principles from that that all sorts of
things one is boy and openness to
mistakes they celebrated every mistake
along that way and the only way you lost
your job in mission control was when you
covered up a mistake oh okay that was
everything every learning because they
only had seven or eight years to do it
something was actually considered
impossible i mean uh pretty much
the other was self-belief jerry bostic
this is one of the most famous ones i
interviewed i asked him what's the link
between age and what you accomplished
and he said you know we were so young we
didn't know it couldn't be
done and and he said so we all believed
that it could be
and they said we got on and did it he
said if we realized what was in front of
us we never even bothered in the first
place yeah so that was a kind of
interesting learning and and so all
these things they are also when i spoke
to them all they are incredibly
conscientious they are incredibly
reliable
you just think
yeah i would put my life in your hands
because that's what the astronauts were
doing
there was an enormous sense of trust
yeah there which was
first time i encountered that actually
how did that come across when it was a
straightness there was a straightness
they never over-egged the pudding
you remember this was the group that
accomplished the impossible and you'd
say so what was your role and they'd all
say i didn't do so much everyone else
that that did it they were quite humble
when they could have gone yeah i was the
person that that did this yeah so steve
bales who
famously made a decision within about 15
seconds that could have gone either way
when they're going to the moon he's
incredibly humble
and and and you think i really like you
and also i would trust you in an
emergency
because you're not going to be there
going i'm the one that's going to save
the day yeah you're just very grounded
and very straightforward it was
interesting it felt like a different
type of success
i think in a few of your books you've
touched on sort of likability and trust
again if we if we're thinking about
principles and and tactics what are the
things that that we can apply in terms
of how does one become more likeable
other than by reading carnegie well
really
i think is the best thing i i think well
first of all don't fake it
so kane has got this great phrase which
is you get more people to like you by
becoming genuinely interested than other
in others than getting them to becoming
interested in you and and people are
fascinating you've got something to
learn from everyone you meet so
develop that genuine
interest
i think
i don't you can fake
likability or as you can but maybe not
for very long
and i think i was thinking about this
yesterday actually
i was thinking when you go to a website
it's a bit like meeting
another person
and you think is that website do i trust
that website is it a likable website
does it help me in what achieve what i'm
trying to do is it's straightforward i
think all the attributes that we decide
about humans we're actually applying to
websites as
well yeah and we have these websites we
visit again and again like the news and
they become like an old friend that's
telling us stuff
and i suppose trust is interesting
because it'd be like sort of blowing up
the balloon isn't it that over time you
trust somebody but only takes one moment
of them lying to you and that just
vanishes so it's this thing which is
quite hard to to get be like so
reputation yeah but it matters it really
matters yeah yeah it's one of the things
that compounds over time but one thing
on on carnegie's point about you know if
you want to be likable then be very
interested become very interested in
other people i think i really took that
to heart when i first read the book i
think around the age of 15 or something
i was like yeah sick this is great stuff
and then there was a bit of a sort of
counter narrative against that in some
blog posts saying that yeah but if you
want to quote get ahead in the world if
you want to achieve success like you
can't just become very interested in
your boss you have to actually offer
something of value um for that exchange
to become equitable rather than like for
example if a if an employee went to
their boss and asked them those
questions was genuinely interested in
the boss the level of like the the power
dynamic at play doesn't necessarily
tie into that any any thoughts on that
i'm not saying i have thoughts
on that i mean i think it is hard when
you've got a status difference like that
because one person's always going to be
suspicious of the other but i think if
it's
genuine
you know if you're genuinely interested
in your boss and their life and what
they're thinking and i mean they're
we're all human we're all got thoughts
and worries and concerns and so on so i
think
i i can still see it working but i i do
see the issue so an interesting thing
the other day this was probably about a
month ago about mask wearing okay
i went to a shop
and only about half the people were
wearing masks
and
of course the the time there's all this
pressure on to wear masks what this shop
assistant did person at the teals did
was very interesting i've got a mask on
or when i paid for something
they said in a very loud voice it's
whatever how much it was and thank you
very much for wearing a mask
i turned around and several people who
hadn't got masks were putting them on
yeah
i thought that was interesting that it
actually rewarded the positive person
not not punished the other ones
and i thought i don't know that
salesperson i bet they're quite likable
because they've
got into somebody else's head and
figured out a way of doing things that
isn't confrontational and isn't
challenging it's just a way of
of of just thinking about it
and collaboration i think is incredibly
important that lucky people were always
looking for the win-win you know and and
and the apollo mission controllers you
know they collaborated this was they
always said they didn't want an ego in
the room if you got an egotist in the
room that was a disaster yeah you wanted
a group of people who wanted to achieve
something and not be somebody and
collaboration was absolutely key to it
coming back to the luck things lately
one of the i think one of the principles
in the luck factor is is this idea that
lucky people tend to expect good fortune
and i think in rip it up you you
mentioned the idea of self-talk
like i feel really enthusiastic i feel
especially productive i feel like my
life is within my control and i was
wondering how does that relate to the
sort of anti-manifestation
anti-affirmation that kind of stuff i
suppose there's like yeah
positive self-talk and to what extent is
that actually useful or it depends on
individuals what i said before was that
for me personally it's not a great thing
if people it's like all these things you
know if if if you find it useful then do
it and if you don't stop doing it you
know we're all different yeah and these
books give general kind of advice so
you know some things will work for you
some things don't for me the
self-affirmation thing doesn't work i
gave a talk two days ago and yesterday
i'll give one on monday as well i don't
stand in the wings going i am a good
speaker i am a good person yeah it
doesn't work what i do do is a trick
that um some vegas performer friends of
mine who'd have to do two shows a day
and i said how do you walk out and feel
fresh
and they said we're in the wings
and we go you know what it's absolutely
true
at some point we'll be too old to do
this
at some point the audience won't turn up
yep at some point this will all go we
love doing it but it will all go and
they let that thought rest and then they
go
it's not tonight though
yeah and walk out
that's nice and that's what i did
because it's it's true you know we think
these things are all going to continue
you know you think what you're doing is
all going to continue well at some point
you won't be doing it anymore
and that is that's the truth you're
putting something else yeah and so just
being grounded enjoying the moment
and not perhaps thinking too far ahead
just know it will vanish at some point
yeah enjoy now i think that's that's
what yeah yeah this reminds me so i the
the other day a few days ago it was i
had i had some friends over for this
like birthday brunch celebration type
thing this was my first time hosting
like a very big like 30 people thing and
i was so stressed because we didn't have
enough food and i was like
it turned out the supermarket opened at
12 noon that day rather than like eight
in the morning like i was just assuming
it would and so i was like frazzled and
stuff and you know people were coming in
in my mind i was just completely like
there's not enough food this is this is
a disaster kind of thing and then one of
my friends uh said hold on
just think that when you're 80 years old
and you're on your deathbed or whatever
you're going to give anything to have
another day like this one yes so
enjoy it and remember that no one cares
about the food yes it's all it's all
fine just enjoy enjoy the day yeah and
there's something about that sort of be
sort of being becoming grounded in the
present moment i think it's really
important i mean but some of the mission
controllers one of their not regrets but
when they said they looked back they
said it felt like gulping fine wine
oh they said that there are these
achievements but you have to knock it
back as quickly as you could to get on
with the next one
instead of just enjoying what is
happening
right now
and i think that's that is very
important
and during talks
you know it's if you've given the talk a
million times before sometimes it's easy
to leave the room mentally and and it's
very hard to remain
grounded and just go i'm just talking to
an audience right now yep what i find
amazing about
psychology of talks is no matter what
the size of the audience whether it's 30
or 300 or even say 3 000
the speed at which that group become one
person
it's phenomenal
so you walk out in front say a thousand
people
and the speed at which that those
thousand people decide to laugh or not
or to be interested or they become one
personality and sometimes when you're
talking to them it takes a while to find
that personality yeah once you got it
you go oh okay it's like talking to one
person yeah i find that phenomenal i i
that's the most
in 25 years of speaking that's the thing
that i find incredible yeah i'm never
talking to a group
this group become one person and i'm
talking to that one person so i don't
get nervous in front of 3000 people
because i know that will become one
person within 10 minutes were you always
like that i think if you've got some
performance instinct you're a little bit
like that but yeah early on i was always
nervous about it and i'm still a little
bit nervous about talks and so on yeah
but i've just been around the block
enough to know that pretty much whatever
happens i can probably cope with it um
changing gears a little bit uh i want to
talk to you about the magic stuff yes
i'm i am semi in the process of
preparing my magic circle audition oh my
goodness you fall
cool
no that's great
i'm joking
yeah um and one of one of the one of the
items on my bucket list is to do a
parlor show at the edinburgh fringe yes
uh i see that you performed at the end
of fringe i was one of the directors for
eight years oh you were i was on the
board of the fringe for eight years yeah
yeah did you perform there as well oh
many times yeah many times what's that
like what's it like well uh it's a
wonderful experience you should
definitely come up and do it it's a tad
competitive because there's about five
and a half thousand shows in town
and so
it's a bit like street entertaining
you're trying to get an audience when
there's a lot of competition around
but
uh you get to do your show many times
and it's a very good way of finding out
whether material actually works so yeah
coming up and you can well what's great
about it is you can go and see so many
other people's show here's an
interesting thing i a couple of years
ago fringe i bumped into an experienced
reviewer friend of mine
and i said to him how can you tell when
someone's trying to hand you a flyer on
the street because it's it's such a
fierce marketplace all the performers
are there handing out flies i said is
there anything you can
any way you can tell whether it's going
to be a good show or not
he said there is actually i always say
to them what other shows have you seen
that you would recommend
and he said if they say oh i haven't
seen anyone else's show
their show will be terrible yeah
where the people that go oh i'd
recommend so and so and so and so he
said normally their shows are great oh
i thought it was really interesting
if you become too isolated and too
self-absorbed in anything
you're not feeding your mind with other
thoughts other perspective other ways of
doing things and that for me is where
creativity always comes from it always
comes from seeing 10 things and then
realizing that there's something in
there that you can use to to to become
not to take anything from what they're
doing but to enhance your own creativity
anyway come on up to the fringe would be
great oh that's that i'll come along to
show you you'll have an audience of one
at least
yeah that's wonderful i'm gonna heckle
like you are not gonna believe it's all
good i've watched all those comedian
response to heckler videos on youtube so
yeah i've got a few things in my mind
but the moment you walk out i'm gonna
say i thought it's gonna be rich
mcdougall i love his stuff
yeah
what sort of magic do you do
mostly so when i was at university i
used to do like walk around with the
balls and things with cards and sponge
balls and occasional flash paper lighter
yes into sponge ball into coin into
invisible deck into the the basic stuff
that can fit into stuff into
tuxedo pockets and yeah yeah what about
you did you ever do color changing pen
knife
uh i did color changing usb memory stick
oh well there we are from a different
generation right yeah okay that would
they i mean you couldn't start with that
old thing of have you lost the red knife
which used to be the old way of getting
into a group oh do it yeah it's
difficult to close up magic because
you're walking up to a group of people
having a good time and then that stops
the moment you get there and there's
always this thing about what's the
psychology of getting into the group
yeah and it used to be with the color
changing pen knife uh which for folks
who don't know is a pen knife that
changes color uh is you say has anyone
lost this red pen knife and when
everyone looks you go how about this
blue one yeah that was the way into it
and it never worked it's a terrible idea
but it was one way into the game yeah
yeah
this is kind of why i stopped doing the
walk around performing because i
performed in a few mabel's for about
three years and it was always so
stressful like
just
kind of get my get my cards together
maybe do a spring or whatever dribble or
something like that like there's a group
over there but they look like they're
having fun and now i've got to go and
like
you know it's like intimidating there's
some good looking dudes there's good
looking girls there everyone's dressed
so nicely and i'm going to interrupt and
be like hi i'm i'm the magician do you
want to want to see a magic trick yeah
this is so awkward yeah i'm just
thinking about it it's making me sweat
you know it's it's it's a very hard way
of making making a living it's why i got
out of it because i did that a lot and
and
you know it's exactly as you say it's a
group of people having a great time then
you arrive
and
then they might have a good time they
might not but i thought yeah
it's not for me my my first experience
of doing this scarred me for life so i
would i'd i was sort of dabbling i'd
seen pen and terror fool us and that
kind of got me into it and kind of
season one when i was in i think i was
about 17 in sixth form and then i
learned like a few basic things pirated
all the dvds at the time because i had
no money
standard uh and then i we had a family
friend who owned a restaurant and i i
heard that you know the magicians were
thinking at a restaurant i was like hey
you know do you have any parties coming
up can i perform and there was this
corporate event
and he was like yeah we've got this
corporate event on friday do you want to
come down i was like all right cool how
hard can that be and then i rocked up to
this corporate event with my pockets
full of like various different decks and
things like that and it was just like
really dark like a sort of men in their
30s in suits
kind of hands and pockets and i went to
the first group i busted out the
invisible deck and it didn't work oh
they picked like a king of something
else yeah i just forgotten the formula
yeah had it and then actually and then
they sort of laughed a bit and then i
sort of went away and i was like oh
and it was it was a horrendous
experience and i just sort of sat in the
corner for the rest of the thing and
then told the guy i know you know it
didn't really work don't bother paying
me et cetera et cetera and then i kind
of uh transitioned from that into uh
doing uh volunteering at the local
hospice right
in south indonesia conceptually very
similar conceptually very similar yeah
but they were much nicer it was like
christmas party is like yeah you know
the nurses the staff all getting
all that all that stuff but no i think i
think there's something around that this
uh sort of
exposing yourself to the to rejection
and battling through and getting
rejected a bunch of times as well that
just builds character in some way yeah i
think it probably does i mean the the
problem i had was that you have to be
entertaining you have to be funny
there's a lot of pressure on a comedy
magician you have to be funny so that's
a lot of pressure and of course when you
give talks as i do a psychologist i
don't need to be funny if i am funny
that's a bonus it's a bonus like oh it's
funny that's
you know what this is going to be an
interesting talk it's not going to be
funny well i don't feel that stress
anymore but no i love magic i love magic
so i've created quite a few shows done
quite a few and i did a
show called experimental which was a
show with no performer standard thing
with creativity is find out what
everyone else is doing and do the
opposite yep and so i looked whenever i
thought every single show in edinburgh
has got a performer i'm going to do a
show with no performer so the audience
came in as just powerpoint slides and
they took them through a whole series of
magic tricks and psychological
experiments and that was called
experimental
and then we did another one which was
blackpool magic convention and magic
live in vegas which was a seance show
but the audience were watching an
infrared feed from a live darkroom
seance so they could see how it was all
done and so i love putting together
these
kind of quite i hope in innovative shows
and most of my close friends are
magicians and it's an amazing amazing
community and i think that's what people
so that there's an interesting point
here that i think we forget how
important community
is
and and magic is incredibly tight-knit
at the one though everyone knows
everyone else everyone is supportive and
and so on but community is really
important in anything and anything
and and and getting a good reputation
within that community i think is
absolutely vital yeah no i think that's
so true i find the same with with
youtube is it like seems like half my
friends are from school in uni and the
other half are youtubers these days and
similarly with our with our youtuber
academy course we find that the people
the beginners that that actually succeed
on youtube are the ones who made friends
yes
because it is a lonely thing sitting in
front of a camera and talking to it just
like writing where a lot of writers will
have other writer friends because they
can all relate to the same thing for a
little bit of a community and there's
this book i read recently called the
minimalist entrepreneur which is about
building businesses
and like technology businesses and stuff
and its main point is start with a
community get really involved in the
community of the thing that you care
about get involved in the forums make
friends go to meetups and then
inevitably you'll find a problem that
community has that you can solve with a
product and then that's a business yes
rather than i'm going to start a
business first and then go out and find
the community around it you know the one
the very first keynotes i did uh so
we're going back 20 25 years was um
it was
sales person of the year for this
particular group i can't remember the
group sales person of the year so
somebody's going to get the award and
sales person a year got the award i was
giving a talk and i was sitting at the
table with sales person of the year who
just won this award and i said to them
what's the secret of being a great
salesperson and i thought they were
going to get to one of those kind of get
to yes quickly
and they looked to the side and went
find a product that everybody wants to
buy
yeah
and it's so true it's so true that you
kind of think the answer is find
something everybody wants and you
already you know you're really halfway
to the the cell on it i remember that
that's that's kind of funny
so versus trying to persuade people to
buy something they don't really want
yeah it's actually just go sorry what's
the problem and and how can i try and
sort of solve that yeah i guess the
final thing i wanted to ask you about
was
what was your common garden street magic
set that was terrible
it was with there's a double act with uh
my friend adrian owen who is now the
same person i went to the states with
who's now very very well known
neuroscientist we're still in touch and
very very good buddies we had this idea
doing a street act together
and
boy we had no money and we had less than
no money
and at the time my girlfriend was a
nutritionist and i said
what's
the smallest amount of money we can
spend on food and still survive
and she said porridge yeah but then with
grapefruit segments because that'll stop
you getting scurvy
no idea this is true that's what she
said so we lived on porridge and
grapefruit segments for two weeks and
the act was that i would come out do
some juggling then i would get adrian
out the audience as if he was a genuine
member of the audience teach him to
juggle uh and he sort of messed up and
we had some fun with that and then
eventually he learned to juggle because
he was a stooge
and then we got a third person out and
did some stuff with them wrapped around
with a little bit of magic it was fairly
bad yeah i mean i'm not saying how bad
it was but if i go in covent garden now
they're still booing down there 25 years
later
and then we went on a tour of the south
coast with the captain fearless magic
show that we put together okay which was
we managed to persuade somebody to give
us a van we did on behalf of cancer
research yeah we got a van another
friend gave us a stage and a sound
system and we just toured around the
south coast doing stage shows
open air for a month
and
probably one of the best months of my
life oh
we had we know what we were doing yeah
we rocked up we did the show put it into
the van we'd occasionally say to
audiences we've got nowhere to stay
tonight anyone got a spare room every
night was an adventure
and and there was
you know both of us look back on it very
very fond because it was the freedom
yeah we were young and could just do
anything um and had no reputation at
that point yeah reputation sometimes
kind of limit you because you think oh
my goodness now i'm supposed to be good
yeah
now the audience are sitting there
expecting
this thing where we could just go out
and
what's it matter yeah it was fun how old
were you at the time uh it'd be about 18
i think
yeah yeah captain field's magic show so
yeah they were like
what prompted you to like were you
trying to make money anyways no no we
were trying to raise money for for
charity but i think it was
we both got the same attitude so we we
sat up in a tree house in
new forest just outside bournemouth and
we we always got these plans and we
thought it was quite fun and we had a
rule we came up with a rule
which is you can only talk about a topic
a plan
three times
and if you haven't done it
by the third time you have to never
mention it again and never do it oh okay
and so that was our rule and we still
live by both of us still do you talk
about it twice and if while you haven't
done it by the third time just forget
about it you're not going to do it
and then a few months later we said
wouldn't it be fun to just tour around
with a big magic show
and we spoke about it twice and the
third time we looked at each other and
said we've got to do it now
and we just we just did it we just went
on the road it's ridiculous
it's fun
every day was this man who broke down
and we ended up doing performing magic
at some surf championship down the south
coast it was good it was good
but um a giant rabbit suit
and that was it was so cool we were
sleeping in the van some nights it was
so cold on one night that adrian climbed
into the rabbit suit and slept in that
and the police came along about three in
the morning because we shouldn't have
been parked where we were banged on side
the van and he sat up in this chair
this giant rabbit scent
and he still claims the look on the
policeman's face was the best sex facial
express you'd ever see of total
bewilderment so there's all these things
well yourself because we were young and
you know just
thought we could get to the moon
that's really inspiring yeah i feel like
well one of my i guess issues is that
because i've been on this sort of career
track since the age of like 12 when you
decide you want to be a doctor and
suddenly it's all about yeah how will
this contribute to my cv et cetera even
even the whole magic stuff is like oh
i'm fine i've got to figure out a way to
tie it in like something about
physiotherapy something about hypnosis
something about like psychology you know
it's all
for for the sake of something else
and i think for me i've never really had
a period of almost like a gap here of
just like doing stuff for its own sake
for the bands rather than because there
is some kind of uh
extra unit of economic output to that
that thing will squeeze i think what i
was reflecting on earlier on that's what
i was saying about having an interesting
life yeah and a fun life because you're
going to look back and and
you know trust me uh get a backache at
some point and go you know i don't feel
like going to bed today and and will it
look back and go yeah it was fun versus
yet i earned a lot of money or i did
these things that other people see as
successful yeah and and so on and i
think
being successful can be a bit
straightjacketing
versus that thing or going you know what
i've always wanted to do and just try it
and see what happens so yeah it's
interesting to you reflect on that yeah
yeah i think so the there's a book i
read recently um called die with zero by
bill perkins um and it's it's whole
premise is that you should be aiming to
die with zero dollars in your bank
account and if you die with anything
more than that you've done something
wrong um and then people be like
what about the kids what about charity
and his whole thing is like easy give
the money away to charity and kids when
they're young when they need it rather
than when they're 68 on average and you
die yes but beyond that point his whole
thing is like
we as as
generally as sort of successful career
type people the um
you know the habit of continuing on the
career thing and making more money is
actually really hard to shake yeah and
yes if you look at what people's net
worth is in their 70s and 80s like what
the hell are they gonna do with all that
money yeah other than just give it away
and so this whole thing is like you know
really think about the life experience
that you want to have
preferably when you're young because
when you're in your 50s
you'll be able to go on cruises and
stuff and you have the money for it but
like you really won't be able to
backpack through eastern europe
absolutely absolutely yeah i mean when i
was young i wanted to be a circus
performer and so i did a course on
flying trapeze
do you know how hard flying trapeze is
do you ever think
boy
it's the hardest thing i mean even just
hanging off the bar yeah and it's so
physically demanding and painful that i
thought this is the last thing i want i
want to do
and so within a couple of weeks i
thought this isn't me but other way i
hadn't done that i've been convincing
myself i'd be the greatest flying
trapeze before but for the rest of my
life for having these regrets but what
about you what what thing if if i don't
know tomorrow you've got two weeks off
three weeks a month off and you can do
anything at all if you've got any
ambitions or anything you've never done
like you know clowning at a circle so
something is there's something where you
go i'd really like to give that a try
the there's a couple of things um one is
i i would love to learn how to snowboard
right that seems like a really cool
thing to do i'd love to actually take
this magic stuff a bit more seriously to
be like you know what i know it's not
gonna make money relative to youtube but
but that's fine i'm just gonna put my
act together audition for the magic
circle try and go try and go for aimc or
what whatever that is and really kind of
go ham on the thing i watched um peter
wardell's uh common garden street magic
dvd back in the day yeah and then he
actually he and i talked on instagram
because he discovered all my videos
randomly and i i've always had in them
in my mind that i'd i'd love to have a
really good cubs and balls act to be
able to do a in common garden so it's
like those random things where it's a
project to work on that's not the aim is
not to make money so pete came across a
few years ago and to interview me spent
the whole afternoon interviewing me
about psychology and magic by the end of
the afternoon he realized he hadn't
pressed the record button
so he reminded me of it the other day on
twitter so pete's great
so you know you're setting that goal of
um performing cups and balls in covent
garden that's totally doable yeah and
totally terrifying yeah i was just like
thinking about it i'm just like oh my
god but that would be an amazing project
that'd be amazing yeah every time i go
to the apple store and common garden i
just like hang around and be like oh
yeah that guy same lines that's good i
like how he's repeated this thing about
a thousand times it's really good and
he's got every single possible outfit
every single heckle from the audience
and it's just there's something about
that that feels really but standing
there and doing it i mean you can give
it a go yeah that'd be that would be
terrifying and wonderful yeah i should
definitely do that yeah i'll come and
watch you oh nice the first show of cups
and balls in covent garden or up in
edinburgh
i will be there i will be there yeah
um
yeah thank you for inspiring me this has
been a good it's been a good a good
session uh well i don't know i would
just chatted but um yeah folks find
anybody helpful that's good absolutely
that's good richard thank you so much
for coming on the podcast uh please
pleasure uh where can people learn more
about you find about your stuff um they
they can look on twitter at richard
wiseman um i've got a website as well
but mostly it's the the twitter stuff
that keeps people up to date
and they can drop me a line
i'll ignore it but they can drop me
another they can drop me a line and
that'd be great but thank you very much
for inviting me and good luck with the
book i um look forward to hearing about
the progress thank you very much all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye